was ist dein tipp wie wird die stimme
deutschlands enden wow was soll ich sein
wie paul die orakelkrake du musst
tun euch alle haben und einen mann eine frau haben
wir eine idee ich habe eine vage idee ja
aber ich könnte'  Ich kann es dir wahrscheinlich nicht sagen,
weil ich eine Wette platzieren und das
ganze Geld gewinnen werde. Okay, du hast Haustiere
im Team. Nun ja, aber ich
sage es niemandem. Okay, okay, du bist
im Team, auf das du wettest  werden es
wissen, denn in diesem Stadium, in dem Sie
so viele Monate mit Menschen gearbeitet haben
und wissen, dass Ray mit
allen etwas länger arbeitet als ich, aber ich
arbeite immer noch seit vier Monaten mit Menschen,
hängt Sie wirklich
an Menschen  und du liebst sie aus
verschiedenen Gründen und du kannst es nicht ertragen,
daran zu denken, dass nächste Woche jemand geht, wir werden
jemanden verlieren und es wird
wirklich schrecklich, weil sie
jetzt wie unsere Freunde sind, weißt du, also tue ich es nicht
Ich habe irgendwie meinen Kopf in Mäusen im
Sound ein bisschen darüber, dass ich das
will  nk darüber, es ist ein bisschen sensorisch, ja,
Sie wissen, so sehr Sie
die Menschen feiern, die durchkommen, und
ihre Aufregung, und es ist ansteckend, Sie
wissen, dass Sie es damit zu tun haben, sich
von Menschen zu verabschieden, die Sie
wirklich waren  anfeuern und durchsetzen wollen
und dir helfen zu wissen, damit du
irgendwie verlierst, wenn du ein bisschen gewinnst, nein
denkst du nicht, wenn diese Show endet, werden viele
der Sänger ein bisschen berühmter sein
als zuvor und sie bekommen mehr Chancen,
ja  und Sie wissen zu Recht, dass das
Tolle an der Stimme anders ist als bei
vielen anderen Castingshows, und der Fokus lag
auf dem Gesang und der
Qualität der Musikalität und ihrer
und ihrer Musikalität, also denke ich, dass
Sie eine Menge davon kennen  Peer, ich würde sogar sagen,
fast jeder, der übrig geblieben ist, hat eine Chance
auf mehr Erfolg. Sie wissen, besonders heiß,
geog, die Alben der Show waren in den
Top-Download-Charts, und ich kann nur sagen,
Team Ray hat das Beste gemacht, ja,
Tim, Köder, ja, Mann  wir rocken es  Ja,
okay, verdammter Fastball,
okay, okay, also viel Glück, vielen Dank
für das Dankeschön der nächsten Woche, und wir
werden sehen und wir werden hören, oh, vielen Dank